he lost it in between his legs and  that ball was tipped so he's allowed to  go back and get it he's going to have to  heave it  [Applause]  you want to see john morant with a  highlight it's not a dunk but right here  he's eyeing the shot clock he's like  okay you go give me this space  but it just all felt very natural and  regular he lost it in between his legs  and  that ball was tipped so he's allowed to  go back and get it he's gonna have to  heave it  [Applause]  you want to see john morant with a  highlight it's not a dunk but right here  he's eyeing the shot clock he's like  okay you gonna give me this space  but it just all felt very natural and  regular